most ridiculous and hilarious part of  the press conference is when Joe Biden  was celebrating the inflation reduction  act as the stock market tumbled this  couldn't have happened without every  single one of you and that's it  it's still dropping because the other  team didn't want to play  and all our distinguished guests CEOs  act Advocates activists thank you for  joining us and what a great day exactly  four weeks ago today I signed the  inflation reduction act in the law what  a great day the the stock market's down  four percent the stock market is in free  fall right now I just signed the  inflation reduction act very very  awkward when Joe Biden is attempting to  celebrate his economic Bill his big  economic Bill to save the economy uh  while you're on the very same screen can  watch the economy in free fall